قال مراسل الجزيره ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اقتحمت مخيم عين السلطان
للاجئين شماليه مدينه اريحه بالضفه
الغربيه اضاف مراسلنا ان قوات الاحتلال
حصرت منزلا وسط اطلاق كثف لقنابل الصوت
والغاز المسيل للدموع واعتقلت شابا بزعم
انه مطلوب لاجهزتها الامنيه قبل
انسحابها واقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مدينه قلقيليه شمالي الضفه
الغربيه وحصرت حي كفر سبه في المدينه
ودهمت قواه الاحتلال عده منازل وبنايات
واعتقلت شابا فلسطينيا تقول انه مطلوب
لديها ومطارد منذ
فتره انضم الينا من طولكرم مراسل الجزيره
ليث جعار نرصد معك ليث اخر المستجدات في
مجمل الضفه الغربيه ونبدا من حيث
[موسيقى]
انت نعم نحن الان نتواجد في مخيم نور شمس
حيث بدات مراسم تشييع جثمان الشهيد فارس
خليفه 37 عاما وهو والد لطفلين وزوجته
حامل في شهرها السادس و يعني خلال الاشهر
القادمه سياتيه المولود الثالث هنا في
المخيم حيث قام الاحتلال في ساعات مساء
الامس باعدامه على حاجز عناب شرق مدينه
طول كرم ومن ثم احتج احتجز جثمانه ليقوم
بتسليمه في ساعات ما بعد منتصف الليل وصل
الشهيد الى هذه المنطقه في مخيم نور شمس
والقى اهله وذويه نظره الوداع الاخيره
عليه قبل ان يتم او البدء بمراسم تشيعه في
داخل المخيم ووصولا الى المسجد هنا حيث
نتواجد في هذه اللحظات في المنطقه المطله
او في منطقه منطقه المحجر تحديدا في مخيم
نور شمس حيث
نقل المشيعون الجثمان الى مسجد المخيم ل
من اجل الصلاه عليه ومن ثم الى مثواه
الاخير الى مقبره الشهداء في مخيم نور شمس
خلال ساعات الليله وساعات الفجر كان هناك
اقتحامات واسعه لجيش الاحتلال في كافه
ارجاء الضفه الغربيه المحتله حيث كان هناك
اقتحامات ل مدين قلقيليه حيث حاصر
الاحتلال منزلين وقام باعتقال اسيرين
محررين ومن ثم الانسحاب بعد ذلك وبعد
اشتباكات مسلحه وقعت في تلك المنطقه على
وقع هذا الاقتحام ايضا نتحدث في مدينه رام
الله كان هناك اقتحام وتفتيش لعدد من
المنازل في او ضمن سياسه الاحتلال
المتواصله في اقتحام مدن الضفه الغربيه
المحتله تحدث ايضا عن مدينه اريحه او مخيم
عين السلطان الذي اقتحمه الاحتلال في
ساعات الفجر وساعات الصباح الاولى حيث نفذ
الاحتلال حملات مداهمات واسعه في المخيم
تلاها اقتحامات لمنازل عده تفتيش والعبث
بمحتويات الفلسطينيين على صعيد
الا الاعتداءات المتواصله من قبل
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه حيث شهدت منذ
ساعات الامس وحتى ساعات الصباح
حمله يعني اعتداءات متواصل على الطرق
العامه تحديدا في شمال الضفه الغربيه
المحتله حيث قام المستوطنون بالهجوم على
مشتل زراعي في دير شرف الى الغرب من مدينه
نابلس وقاموا بحرق جرافتين ومركبه ومن ثم
حرق
ال المشتل وعدد من الاشجار ايضا عند دوار
سليمان الفارسي في شرق المدينه او جنوب
المدينه عفوا تحديدا في بلده حواره حيث
قام المستوطنون بالقاء الحجاره على مركبات
الفلسطينيين اثناء مرورهم باتجاه مدينه
نابلس او الخروج منها ما ادى الى تكسير
عدد من هذه المركبات ايضا في بلده بورين
حيث شهدت هذه البلده وهي جنوب مدينه نابلس
حرق لمركبه فلسطينيه واعتداءات متواصله
على الفلسطينيين في ترمس عيه الى الى
الجنوب الى الشمال عفوا من محافظه رام
الله خلال ساعات الامس وساعات الليل حاول
المستوطنون الهجوم على احد المنازل
المتطرفه عن او المطرفه عن البلده وا
محاوله حرقها لكن الشبان تصدوا لهم
ومنعوهم لكن الاحتلال اطلق النار صوب
الفلسطينيين في محاوله لحمايه المستوطنين
في استمرار جرائمهم في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله شكرا جزيلا لك من طول كرم مراسل
الجزيره ليث جعار